друзі всім привіт зараз поговоримо про
зброї та про те як вона змінює ситуацію
кардинально і про те, як росіяни
відхопили під родзинками ізюмський шлях і
взагалі там під куп'янською відхоплюють по
повною зараз розповімо про що докладніше
ви підписуйтесь на канал щоб нічого
не пропустити тут ми обговорюємо головні
політичні та економічні та військові
новини сьогодні військова тема тема номер
один і коли ви тут ви нічого важливого
не пропустіть тому підписуйтесь
вовни лайкайте відео коментуєте та
дуже важливо, щоб більше людей побачило і
кожна ваша реакція на відео збільшує
кількість людей які його переглядають
значить дізнаються правду тому допомагайте
мені
поїхали у нас є інформація про те, що
україна дуже суттєво проводила
російське угруповання яке
збиралася атакувати донбас з
харківській області пам'ятаєте скільки було
розмов що вони там йдуть
на родзинки і через родзинки вони там хочуть
оточити наше угруповання говорили
говорили їхні пропагандисти у цьому
захлинаючись розповідали барана якось
всі замовкли а чому та тому що
колона яка йшла знаєте як знайшла
йшла, але не дійшла ось як з ручної
відбувається загалом в Україні так і там
сталося накрили її роздовбали
понтонну переправу через яку вони
прийшли донець вони виявилися затиснуті і
роздовбали їх там повністю плюс до того
наші хлопці та дівчата помстилися за
краматорськ і кілька точок дуже
грамотно точково накрили під куп'янською
ще одну частину російського угруповання та
все і стало вже не таким весело друзі та
це все . у це досить старе
радянська зброя тобто це те, що ми
робимо за допомогою але не найкращого в
світі але добре знайомого нам але не
найкращої у світі зброї а ситуація
змінюється їх нам іде дуже сильне
серйозна зброя та години якраз про це
хочу вам докладніше розповісти так що
мені які у нас є новини
перших ось з'явилося відео у Польщі
такі склади йдуть до України подивіться
на літачку
на україни ж піднята та друзі це сау
сау який самохідні артилерійські
установки рухаються їх україні рухається
серйозними темпами тут ще одна подія
сталося 100 танків т-72 пошуки які
були біля польші стояли стояли біля
любліно і зникли і кажуть що десь
вони так зникли що можуть де ти
з'явиться і хтось за поребриком дуже
добре це може на собі відчути
може в сафарі братимуть участь
знаєте з до знаменита одеська сафарі
ну загалом цікава новина ну і
звичайно важливо тому, що танки нам ой
як потрібна справа в тому, що дивіться
спочатку натаном давала таку зброю
наук США Великобританія в першу чергу
інші країни то в міру сил давали нам
така зброя як вони вважали що україна
не витримає туди росії
тобто як централізована держава
далі почнеться партизанщина буде така
афганістану і потрібний буде белена in
low щоб спалити російські танки у
листах і в засідках і з-за рогу будинку не
так далі на україна всіх здивувала і
утримала удар спочатку пригальмовував
русню потім зупинила цього російського
військового монстра, а потім почала бити
з-під києва викинуло з по чернігову
викинуло з-під сума викинула
подивіться відео з тростинця де все
це докладно розповідаю в описі
залишу заслання і тоді вони почали нам
давати пзрк вже stinger і більше
не бачать що українці шикарно цим вміють
всім користуватися з дуже ефективно та
тепер вже йдеться про те, що США можуть
не давати нам важку артилерію
йде про ракети гарпунні ніж 140
йдеться про дуже вже серйозну зброю і це
звичайно дуже важлива для нас друзі
для всіх новина ось що таке наприклад
ракети МВМ 140 я вже вам розповідав що
ці ракети які та ось можуть майже
практично дістати до Москви самі
виставковій точці України так просто
збіг це просто збіг ось що
у них радіус дії збігається і це
дуже серйозна зброя послухайте що про
про це говорить військовий експерт
протитанкової зброї йде потоками
трона камікадзе ось якщо американці ми
ще навіть мжм 140 до яких я говорю
який може стріляти до 500 км
але в нього різні модифікації швидше
всього не передадуть за який стріляти
на 2 7 кілометрів і це чимала цифра
що американцем річ ​​у американців є
понад 800 пускових установок та близько 6
тисяч ракет тут по центру передадуть я
подивився краще повністю
але 40 пускових установок і 200 ракет
подивлюсь потім як
будуть хоча б державні кордони
хтось підходитиме
навіть одиночна людина або скажемо так
маленький підрозділ не вони не в цьому
сенс час працюють на користь край або
гарпуни які дають нам це
протикорабельні ракети, які нам
Британія дає взагалі британці молодці
борис джонсон грація до queen молодці
Демонструють лідерство дуже сильно
серйозніше більше джонсу не тільки книги
про черчілль написав але він схоже і
багато перейняв
готувались мабуть знайти ось він
відчув з і з усіх лідерів ось
зараз західних він звичайно
демонструвати але дуже крутий ось
таке лідерство дякую йому за це і
дякую окреме за гарпун і тому що
це потужна зброя яка може бути до
280 кілометрів і не лише морськими
цілям послухайте що каже військовий
експерт місяць тому вони домовились
Туреччини
також надати їм платформою
автомобільний мобільний на який будуть
встановлені
корабельний модуль ракети гарпун
ці ракети гарпун має можливість
обстрілювати як морські судна так і
наземні цілі на відстані 250 кілометрів
тобто з отриманням гарпуну
українська армія на порядок збільшити
свої вогневі можливість
але
вона зможе знищувати кораблі, які
будуть підходити ближче 200 перекласти
кілометрів до цього не корабель і тобто
ними мені the queen's ми не зможемо
атакувати але з російським кораблям
підійти та обстріляти одесу як вони це
робили
почуватися як вдома у себе ось це
ось шастати туди-сюди цим іржавим кором
там уже буде ой як не просто і
трішечка стискатиметься в них там
щось друзі це дуже звичайно важливо
для нас і новина та важлива для нас
інформація навіть це ж заходу
несистемно підходять до питань означає
сьогодні відбудеться у пентагоні та закрите
нарада
найбільших постачальників зброї для
американської армії та це і лоб хіт
леджер dmx загалом у найбільші компанії
і найкращу зброю у світі вони на
насправді виробляють так пінта він
буде з ними розмовляти про те, що
потрібно Україні і йдеться і про
артилерії важкої і нас
як і раніше дуже думати того що ось
гарпуни чомусь так важливі і пішла слабка
місце моря і слабке місце повітря
говорили самі з першого дня так вони
залишаються і ми можемо за допомогою західного
зброї звичайно цю ситуацію
істотно суттєво друзі покращити
і ось вони на цій нараді будуть
обговорювати як Україні допомогти при цьому
друзі не обговорюватимуть варіант
затяжний саме кілька років звичайно
мої такого не хочемо я сподіваюся цього і не
буде але те, що вони році дайте вони
готують різні сценарії - це що у них і
такий сценарій на столі насправді
для нас це важливо, бо нам зброя
потрібно буде і завтра, і післязавтра, і вони
це вже обговорюють і вже з погляду
як це треба дати Україні закон про
ленд-лізі, а якою ми самі говорили
що все спростити передачу цього
зброї це дуже важливо та й тоді друзі
з цією зброєю наші тут у котрий так
фантастичні стануть однією вже немає там
я думаю це найкраща армія в Європі
сьогодні теж ні в кого не викликає
сумнівів але вже стануть однією з найкращих
армій у світі і звичайно нам це дуже
потрібно тому що це наш вихід у нас на
насправді всієї ось цієї історії з
росією у нас є три виходи на 1 що
вона розвалиться ніж цим хворий
тільки путін там хвора більша частина
російського суспільства імперіалізму
мілітаризмом і так далі й у нас є
три виходи першої що вони там всі
розваляться і просто перестануть тоді
представляти загрозу це дуже гарний
вихід поки ми його не бачимо і не
відомо скільки часу ще до нього
станеться їсти вихід другий що там
навіть не перестане бути пуну при путіні
зрозуміло нічого бути не може перестане
бути путін в результаті якихось подій
або природних чи дасть бог
неприродних у чому його щоб не
стало й далі зміна режиму при
якої потрібно обов'язково досягти та й
mpi реалізації Росії означає все це
потім відродитися знову загроза висять
треті друзі сценарій для вас стати
ізраїль ці як там цей що слова
говорити мишкам станьте їжачками та ось
ми можемо стати насправді такою грудкою
у горлі будь-кому стати країною
настільки сильною що щоб там не
було в голові у росіян у когось
було ще вони навіть задуматися не посміють
про те, щоб нас торкнутися ось цей варіант
насправді він найкращий тому що
те, що залежить від нас перші два
варіанта від нас залежить звичайно теж але
побічно а цей безпосередньо залежить від нас
це не тільки військова справа це військова
справа політика інформаційна культурна
політика це дипломатія не всі разом
ось все разом і ми можемо це зробити
тому друзі йдемо цим шляхом але й
тоді ось як зараз уже у рашку 40
відсотків армії не хочуть воювати
послухайте багато хто з тих контрактників
які були на київському напрямку
чернігівському з вузького їх виділимо росію
щоб далі перекинути спочатку в
Білгород і далі тепер українці багато
з них ми зараз побачимо повідомлення що
починає відмовлятися далі воювати за
багатьом причин є причина того що
вони не розуміють навіщо ця війна 1 чекала
проблема звичайно ж низький моральний дух
те що ні не було нормального постачання
вони багато з них там голодували за
два-три дні їх не був нормальних там
речей не було нормальної підтримки допомоги
постачання боєприпасів тому люди
банально відмовляється частина бойових
дій поки що відсоток не дуже високий
але помітно за нашими прикидками за нашими
відчуттям
говоріть і там 20 40 відсотків
практично у кожному підрозділі
пише рапорту, що вони відмовляються
далі воювати та ось так воно є і
коли ще ми посилимося таким потужним
зброєю коли ніхто до нас і ріжка
захлинеться у своєму бажанні на знову
атакувати і ніхто до нас уже друзі не
полізе, а насправді зможемо
потужною серйозною країною одним з
світових лідерів рухатися вперед я
впевнений так це і буде і ми з вами в
цьому зіграємо важливу роль друзі тримаємо
буд